this video is sponsored by noir DPN I
want you to join devs deaths when a
character from Alex Garland's new
limited series devs gets access to a
groundbreaking technology the
significance of that tech isn't
expressed primarily through exposition
so tell me about does I can't tell you
anything no one knows what the dev team
does except the dev team I wouldn't even
say the devs team knows what the dev
team does few words are used to describe
what it does or how it works
it's presented instead as an encounter
with something spiritual or alien
[Music]
the music and set design invokes
something not concrete and
understandable but otherworldly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an approach Garland's used to
present the completely alien in his last
film annihilation
and more subtly to present the birth of
AI consciousness in ex machina
[Music]
it's an approach to showing a leap
forward and technology that he didn't
come up with he's borrowing it from one
of the greatest sci-fi films of all time
[Music]
[Music]
instead of explaining how something
works we see how people respond when
they encounter the thing it's not
dialogue and exposition but music visual
design and cinematography that worked
together to create the feeling of
encountering something new
[Music]
[Music]
whether it's a machine gaining
consciousness an alien consciousness
acting as a biological machine or a
machine as something completely alien to
us Garland's interest is the same it's
not in revealing the mechanics of those
things how they work but in their
implications Garland's interest is in
how we respond when we encounter the
appearance of consciousness in a machine
an alien that seems to defy our physical
and material laws or a machine that
changes how we understand our own
consciousness and that is so good when
we get to tell the story you know I
turned to Caleb and he looked up at me
and he said you're not a man you're God
yeah but I didn't say that so anyway he
focuses on the questions these things
raise their philosophical and spiritual
implications
[Music]
I know it's really hard
it really shouldn't be in me
it will be in all of us you feel bad for
Ava
feel bad for yourself man what are we
supposed to do unravel a lifetime of
moral experience and learn what has
always seemed true these things they run
deep yeah they do but he's not
interested in giving an answer to these
questions just presenting a situation as
a thought experiment and adding to the
conversation what if instead of making
art without thinking he said you know
what I can't paint anything unless I
know exactly why I'm doing it
what would have happened almost none of
us commit suicide and almost all of us
self-destruct in some way in some part
of our lives it wasn't just that there
were contradictory States they were
absolute states each was complete in
itself leaving no room for the other but
I held them both nature is ever-present
in his work the boundaries between
technology and nature seem blurred at
first glance it might seem that
humanities technology is encroaching on
nature where that nature is encroaching
on human development but I think garland
is showing these things more as a step
in development it's not technology or
biology encroaching on the other but one
emerging out of the other a
transformation in form of something that
is fundamentally the same I think for
garland there's no separation between
nature a lien humanity and technology
they're all material physical so then
why present things stylistically in such
a subjective way one that seems to
invoke the metaphysical I think it seems
very like we're living in a dream state
I'm pretty sure we are and I think
that's just to do with the nature of how
we experience the world we experience in
a subjective way and the thing I've
learned most as I've got older in some
respects is is the degree to which
reality is counterintuitive and that the
things that are presented to us as
objective turn out not to be objective
and quantum mechanics is full of that
kind of thing but actually just
day-to-day life is full of that kind of
thing as well because for Garland while
these things might all exist as material
we can only perceive them through our
subjective experience an experience he
equates to dreaming or the psychedelic
state and it's this subjective
experience not the underlying material
reality like Garland so masterfully
reveals in his work
[Music]
thanks to Nord VPN for sponsoring this
video the show devs highlights some of
the darker more sinister aspects of
Silicon Valley a larger companies and
governments are encroaching on our
privacy as time goes on on the Internet
we were losing control of our privacy
and a VPN is a way that you can take
back some control of your privacy I've
been using Nord VPN for years now and my
experience with them has been great they
have super fast servers thousands to
choose from in 60 plus countries you get
up to six simultaneous connections you
can use it on your phone your desktop
your laptop and you can try Nord VPN
risk free with our 30-day money-back
guarantee when you go to Noor VPN comm
slash Thomas flight and use code Thomas
flight you get 70% off a three-year plan
plus one additional month for free
that's Nord VPN comm / Thomas flight to
start taking back some control of your
internet thanks so much for watching my
patrons get access to a monthly podcast
where I talk about what I've been
watching that month you can get access
to that and more when you go to
patreon.com/scishow
[Music]